hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar transcriptomics to decipher
the pathobiology of drug resistance and
enable future targeted therapeutics
presented by dr. yesh M Bookman polar an
assistant research professor in the
department of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine at Indiana University School of
Medicine i'm susie valdez and I'll be
your moderator for today's educational
webinar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located at
the lower left of your presentation
window type your questions into the box
that appear on the screen we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you're viewing this
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window click on the screen
icon located at the lower right if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on a support button
at the top right of the presentation
window or use that Q&A button and let us
know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
click on the button in the bottom left
hand corner and follow the process to
obtain your credits i'd now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Yasim
Gookin polar dr. Bookman Poehler is an
assistant research professor in the
department of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine her research centers on
mechanisms of resistance to standards of
care therapy and the identification of
novel therapeutic targets in breast and
tymek cancers more specifically her work
has emphasized targeting of fa2 receptor
tyrosine kinase protein kinase C beta
anti tubulins
and
Tork 1 & 2 in colon breast cancer and
tymek mulligan sees her lab developed
and characterized the only human die
Moniz cell line IU tab 1 dr. Gookin
Polar's current research uses
next-generation sequencing also known as
NGS next-generation microarrays such as
clary MD human transcriptome analysis
and preclinical models to understand the
transcriptional regulation mechanisms of
resistance and develop novel targeted
therapies the ultimate goal of her
research is to prevent development of
reoccurrences and improve the quality of
life for all patients please join me in
welcoming dr. Bookman Poehler along now
turn the presentation over to her
welcome doctor
thanks Susie for this nice introduction
before I start I would like to thank to
Thermo Fisher Scientific and lab Rhodes
for enabling this webinar as you see
from the title I will talk about the
importance of transcriptomics to
understand the biology behind the drug
resistance in cancer and develop future
therapeutic targets and strategies for
this disease let me give you a brief
introduction so the main failure to the
therapies may be due to the resistance
so the resistance can be in acquired
form which is occurs after a drug
treatment after a certain time or it can
be pre-existing at the beginning of
therapy it is already resistant of
course there are multi factors for drug
resistance happening and most of the
time because the cancer is very
heterogenous and we don't have enough
knowledge about each cancer subtypes and
also different targets and that for
specific treatments are not available so
what are the tools to understand
resistance in a preclinical research
studies of course reform of the central
dogma of molecular biology meaning that
in a very simplistic form DNA makes RNA
RNA makes proteins so the information
from DNA is transformed to the protein
and there may be alterations in the
active DNA level like mutations which we
detect with the DNA sequencing or there
may be differences in the gene
expression at the messenger and they
level
we have rt-pcr and conventional micro
arrays and also ultimately the protein
is the gold standard and we measure the
protein expression where the enzyme
assays units the chemistry and other
essays are coming so these are all fine
and luster to the case especially we
used to use these techniques however
with the introduction of the
next-generation sequencing all real is
immensely changed
mostly we thought always that coding
regions coding RNAs are the most
important and they are translated to the
proteins however these new technologies
give us the complexity of the iana world
mainly there are non-coding rnas that we
don't know but they are therefore or
there are multiple splice variants we
don't know again although they don't
code some of them a protein they are
still have some function so with these
new technologies we started
understanding that it is much more
complex than we until now know in that
sense we started analyzing the
non-coding rnas and then the splicing
factors or other splicing regulatory
proteins in breast cancer progression
and resistance and published some papers
this also changed the understanding in
molecular pathology of breast cancer and
their contribution especially at the
regulatory level so let me give a brief
introduction for the non-coding RNAs
non-coding RNAs usually classified based
on their size or structure is that if
they are less than 200 base pairs they
called a small non-coding RNAs if they
are greater than 200 base pairs they are
named as long noting rnase so among
these non-coding RNAs especially you can
see here micro rna's are the most
established and well developed in cancer
and the other ones like SI rnas or pbrn
ace small nuclear are an instrument with
no enemies they are still in their
influences on the other hand a long walk
on a kinase can be classified based on
their location it can be intergenic
intronic they can be antisense or others
of course there are for the small
non-coding RNAs a ribosomal RNAs and
transfer RNAs that we always thought
they are involved on the housekeeping
the processes and never thought in the
context of the cancer however
alterations of those genes whether
expression level or other aberrant
structural alterations also may involve
in the cancer and drug resistance so
with this slide I just would like to
give some examples for non-coding RNAs
in breast cancer
they are mostly classified based on
their function so on the upper side you
see they can regulate chromatin
modification hot air is one of the best
examples for this in chancer and
metastasis and now that one is another
one involved in the nuclear organization
of course there are others like act as a
protein or a Mayan attackers or snow RNA
hosts or they involved in multiple
signaling that affect the cancer
mechanisms and drug resistance also the
next generation analysis sequencing
analysis evolved our understanding in
terms of importance of alternative
splicing mainly splicing is an RNA
editing you can see on the left hand
side were the introns the intervening
sequences can be separated from the
exons the coding sequences the premature
RNA is converted to the mature RNA
having exons only and this further
translated to the proteins and of course
splicing can happen in different forms
we call alternative splicing events here
you see the based basic five basic
events and the different splicing will
end with different protein isoforms at
the beginning on the right hand side you
see the exon skipping where the exon can
be skipped or it can be included the
another one is mutually exclusive exons
and two exons can be skipped or included
or one each other or this splicing can
occur in the five prime donor of the
exon or trip right or an intro can be
retained so those all of them can end in
different functions the function at the
end could be similar or opposite
therefore very important to understand
their importance especially in cancer
and compared to drug resistant forms so
here I would like to give a very brief
summary also it has been established
well that alternative splicing or splice
variants are very important in every
step of cancer hallmarks initially
introduced by Hanahan and Weinberg as
you see here you can see in the
proliferation or growth evading growth
suppressors angiogenesis a new system
whatever the hallmarks is you see these
are alternative splicing variants that
can make a big difference in the
function of the process
so what is the most appropriate
technology to study all these
transcriptome changes in preclinical
research studies well here on this life
I just want to take brief information
about how it used to be like the last 2d
case we were so excited about the
combination micro arrays the key to gene
expression we can see differences and
there are multiple differences existing
we do a a microarray essay and however
of course they are limited in terms of
their gene expression and they can be
biased
what kind of if it's whole genome or it
used to be like 500 genes you choose it
so depends on what do you do but it was
biased of course with the introduction
of the RNA sequences this whole concept
changed and then we were so excited
about that that we can detect some
normal transcripts they can detect some
non-coding RNAs or alternative splicing
variants however this also depends on
the depth and coverage so here recently
the next-generation micro arrays are
introduced so how did it if I see that
if I tell the difference between them so
the very original exon erase 3 primed x
on arrays in the bottom of the right
hand side the figure you see that most
of the probes are focused on the 3 pride
ant and gene erase you see the clocks in
the exomes there they were not that
covered but with the introduction of the
clearing essays here you can see the
clearing s si you see extensive probe
coverage for the exon and for the
clearing D array ultimate you can detect
the overall transcriptome analysis and
you can see multiple exons multiple
probes for the exon and for displaced
junctions is
see on the left hand side this is
because of the it was developed by
combining 15 data sources listed here
and that extended or expanded the
coverage of both human coding and
non-coding transcripts on if you look in
a more detail to the next-gen and micro
arrays here on the right hand side you
see the the actual clearing the array
and then on the left hand side it
explains why they are so extensive
because for the Exxon / X omnia 10
probes and for the splice Junction you
have four probes covered that provides
extensive coverage for the both low
abundant high or alternative splicing
variants so let me give a done a
comparison between clearing D and RNA
seek since these are the method methods
that you would like to choose when you
want to do the home transcriptome
analysis so for RNA sequencing if you
look at the depth if you choose 30 to
50,000,000 reads you can only focus on
the high expresses
so it's very much depth dependent if you
increase this 200 million reads then 32
percent of the more expresses there and
even for the long known long non-coding
or alternative splicing you have to
really increase your depth or even 300
millions reads and so that you can
detect all these transcriptomic changes
on the other hand for clearing Lee is
just one si so because of the extensive
coverage of both human coding and
non-coding genes you don't need to worry
about the which-which that I need to
choose you can detect high expresses
with sa low expresses to the level of
one point five to three transcripts per
cell you can detect long non-coding RNAs
alternative splicing and anything you or
normal transcripts anything you want
because of
you don't vary about the depth but with
RNA sequencing you are limited because
for every purpose you have to use a
different depth which it's kind of
complicates the situation so also
another advantage I like is the time -
results if we don't usually calculate M
be like three DS three days four
experiments and then you have the tech
transcriptome analysis console and you
import your data and you need you to
start analyzing your data and going back
to the bed lab and coming back so you
can parallely use both of them all the
time as a molecular biologist it's a big
advantage for me compared to the RNA
sequencing and you never really
dedicated by informatician to analyze
the data intensively and then give to
you which is very time dependent also
another advantage of clear MD is if you
compare with RNA sequencing so no
ribosomal RNA depletion is for home
transcriptome gene is necessary but in
the case of anything you have to deplete
it and if you want to analyze different
samples like blood you have no globulin
reduction or also from time to time
users FFPE samples formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded they are very
challenging samples there is a pickle
kit available that also detects very low
amounts and also challenging samples
which is very challenging for anything
of course also chlorine being is very
cost effective compared to the RNA
sequencing so with that I would like to
present to you two projects from my own
preclinical research studies as Suzy
said and my focus is tiny cancer in
breast cancer so the first project will
involve the tiny cancer and then trying
to identify therapeutic targets in time
a tailored cancer let me give a brief
background for the timing cancer I mean
the time Mama's and time it carcinomas
they are rare cancers of thymus gland
thymus gland is a gland that is
important for immune function mostly so
it is one person of this gland is
epithelial cells and the cancer develops
in these 1% in epithelial section so
according to the World Health
Organization wh oh they have classified
the timer was classified into five
different histological subtypes as you
see here a a B b1 b2 and b3 and tiny
carcinoma used to be type C before is a
separate section or separate cancer but
the thymus usually are more intimate
than the time carcinoma and however all
type of timers can spread to Pillar or
can metastasize but their speed is
different on the other hand type 3
enormous and also tiny carcinomas they
are the most aggressive tumors and they
are the most types that are resistant to
existing therapeutics so of course
because it's a rare cancer
therefore there are lots of limitations
in terms of diagnostic and treatment
strategies so usually as a standard of
care other these therapies are from the
other cancers like mostly lung because
it's closeness to the thymus although
they are totally very different in terms
of the biology and therefore limited
normal biology therapeutics existing and
usually using just a standard share of
therapies by now so in order to
understand the time OMA and pilot
carcinoma we started we studied the
molecular profiles
Noorie chemical research and so we
developed a gene signature to determine
and the metastatic behavior of time of
us and also to distinguish between tiny
carcinoma and from time MoMA
so here the left hand side the Venn
diagram shows the gene signature the
overlapping genes in thymoma and tiny
carcinoma also the unique ones to tie
normal are tannic carcinoma also we
decided to do a protein protein analysis
to determine which gene or gene
signaling would be the driver for this
cancer and then we can develop or find
some therapeutics to test on the right
hand side you see the analysis of
protein-protein interaction mainly we
ended up with three hubs as you see the
drivers for each of the genes SD c 2j p
h1 and SLC 982 and they are all
connected to each other by a protein
called UBC mainly a bt c pathway is
involved and this UBC is mainly
regulates the protein turnover so then
this led us to the drug called
bortezomib
it's a proteasome inhibitor it's mostly
in use for the multiple myeloma based on
the disease namely devote all these
biology and we have two different models
cell line models to test this drug and
are you tap one it's a time oma cell
line in the my mama cell line that we
have developed in the lab and the second
model is tiny carcinoma model which is
very aggressive therapy resistance cell
line so we chose these two models to see
the differences between both biology and
in terms of the therapeutics on the left
hand side you see
both of them cell lines are resistance
to cisplatin cisplatin is used as a
standard of therapy in english disease
so it's the ic50 the inhibition at the
50% cell inhibition is 11 micrometer or
19 micromolar which is that means highly
resistant then and we tested the same
cell line models to abort a sonic and
you see that the toilet carcinoma is
highly sensitive to this drug about 200
nano molar levels which is very hard to
have a non ammonia level drug response
on the other hand the thymoma cell line
didn't reach the IC 50 which was okay so
we are excited to see a difference
between these models by using this drug
so then we decided to do clarium the
analysis to do to look at the
transcriptomic a basis for therapeutic
response using the tag for it's the new
version of transcriptome analysis
console and understand the biology
behind here on the right hand side you
see the workflow mainly you import the
cell files which are cell a expression
intensity files expression files and
then you can perform either gene level
or exon level or alternative splicing
level analysis and then these analysis
are very interactive as I wanna show in
the upcoming slides and also another
aspect or characteristic I like is you
can connect the location or X on
location or gene whatever you want
easily to the other databases such as
and sample and CBI or UCSC that makes
you understand part of the biology in a
very short time so we first looked at
the gene level data to compare the
differences of tiny carcinoma
with the drug treated or not treated or
thymoma with the drug and non-treated
conditions here we have identified 489
genes for the tiny carcinoma cell line
and then 279 genes and when you treat
the cells in terms - in response to
participate in this slide you see a
different level like the pie charts will
show you the group for example for the
upregulated genes we have different
groups it tells you whether it's a
coding or non-coding or a multiple
complex gene and here multiple complex
means it's very complex it has both
coding and non-coding part so it is
interestingly the coding region coding
genes are very very small 11% and most
of them are either multiple complex or
non-coding and the same for the
unregulated fund another graphic view is
you can use volcano plots and then you
can click these individual dots up
regulated means for the red and then
green water down regulated when you
click it it it tells you it connects you
to the tabular format here is the gene
list you can choose whatever filter you
want of course the default is the
p-values or full change you can use the
API post discovery rate or you can use
from the drop down many customized
annotations in the upper corner that
makes you whatever there are more
features that you can use and to
understand nor in in detail and then the
groups of course showing coding multiple
complex or non-coding and gives you an
brief overview about the gene that is
down regulated or up regulated here I
show an example you see the we
highlighted gene HSPA
or HSPA 1a so these pitcher proteins are
upregulated in response to participate
in the tymek carcinoma cell line so i
especially chose the upregulated ones
because usually to downregulated you see
that most of the oncogene or other
interpretive or collaborative genes are
regulated but in this case heat shock
protein is upregulated so usually they
are protected from apoptosis this also
suggest us that the this can be a
potential drug resistance mechanism and
for bertazzoni plainly using in vivo and
therefore it is highly guiding us that
we need to also test the combination of
porters Olympic the inhibitors of
targeting the heat shock proteins so it
gives you further idea behind these
mechanisms of sensitivity versus
insensitivity
here you see an alternative splicing you
and I continue to gene view and here
actually I feel turd with the non-coding
genes so that you can see that you can
also filter based on the group
non-coding or multiple coding or
anything so here I chose the hot air and
one which we know in from the other
cancers there are other novel
transcripts but we will focus on the hot
air and one is its importance in the
drug resistance or other cancers so then
we decided to focus also study
alternative splicing events and in
timing carcinoma in response to
bortezomib here you see that the
distribution of the alternative splicing
events so the majority of events 62
percent about intern retention and we
that follows by the cassette exons about
22 percent
well this is interesting because most of
the time in other Chancellor's we have
the Casa Texans the most important
affecting but this drug is important for
alteration intron retention so this
gives us the level of event but events
are important here is the alternative
splicing view namely the blue boxes on
the on the right hand side you can see
that the splicing is based the exon
splicing is based on the two algorithms
and then made these algorithms means
that how much X own expression level is
changed between the two conditions in
this case drug treated versus not
treated and after you subtract the gene
level changes and exon splicing index
giving you the level of the fault it's a
high or low and of course you can also
filter based on the exon P values FDR
p-values and you can look at the x own
event scores mainly it's a scale from
zero to one and if it's closer to the
one it tells you how likely is the
splicing event in this case so here's an
example for the on the left hand side
the splice variants visualization you
can see that for each of the conditions
sorry it's if it's a little bit small
and the letters but for each cell line
it shows you the individual intensity
blue or yellow and then you can see the
signal levels sample level signal levels
and also on the bottom you see in the
Box the very red and then highlighted
the splicing event levels either red or
green so it gives you in detail which
exon or PSR probe selection region
important and you can you can see here
but in the actual software you can click
to the box the red box and it connects
you further to the other databases such
as ensemble or UCSC browser based on the
chromosomal location and you can
immediately connect yourselves where you
are or other biological significance
type of related analysis on the right
hand upper side you see the RNA I
support level visuals visualizations and
then here you can see the example
transcript numbers and if you look at
the highlighted a blue line you can see
this particular exon or PSR is present
in some of the transcripts but not all
so it tells you which exon number is
included or excluded based on the
transcript I so far so after this
analysis we decided to look at as a
complete what else is changed besides
the proteasome system pathway because
this is the main focus or mechanisms of
action of the bortezomib so we also see
that alterations in other pathways such
as nuclear receptor make a pathway major
signaling pathway circadian written
related genes met kinase signaling
which is very exciting that we even go
all after this because most of them have
also potential therapeutic agents
available as a conclusion of the first
project we identified the ubiquitin
proteasome pathway is a key hub in
timing tumors especially in tymek
carcinoma and more to--some it has a
therapeutic utility in tiny carcinoma
compared to the time Noma and at the
transcript level we have identified
transcript transcriptome isoforms that
as a next step we would like to
understand further they are biological
significance and also we would like to
as a next step perform in vivo studies
in particular combined porterson with
the heat shock targeting inhibitors to
improve the efficacy and to prevent the
potential and resistance for this truck
so I'm gonna switch gear to the second
project that is involving the
understanding of the endocrine
resistance in breast cancer so let me
give a brief background breast cancer is
a very heterogeneous disease and
endocrine therapies is most of the
therapies especially for the breast
cancer that has estrogen receptor
expression available so namely estrogen
breast cancers about let's say 60 75 %
is driven by the estrogen receptor so
therefore it's important to detect
whether it's there or not and if there
is an estrogen receptor expression then
definitely endocrine therapy is the
first choice however despite the
successes of endocrine therapy there is
still resistance is a big challenge so
it can be in the
and pawns as I mentioned earlier it can
be interesting or acquired and tamoxifen
the most heavily studied drug about
fifty percent resistance for as a
first-line therapy so let me give a
brief summary for the types of endocrine
therapy available in breast cancer so it
can be a selective estrogen receptor
modulators tamoxifen is a good example
for that
it's an antagonist for ER mainly it
competes with the estrogen and the
ligand for the estrogen receptor and
then because of the competition its
antagonist but it can be some agonist so
it's kind of not complete inhibition but
still a very good inhibition for the
aroma taste inhibitors is another class
which inhibits the enzyme RNA pace which
synthesizes the estrogen so it's an
indirect inhibition of estrogen but it's
especially very successful in
postmenopausal woman because of the
estrogen is driven based on the aroma
taste rather than estrogen itself and
then the third group is the estrogen
receptor down regulate this may need
those drugs down regulating the estrogen
chapter and facet X or food westrom is a
good example for this type of drugs and
there are of course multiple mechanisms
of endocrine resistance have been
reported and postulated and suggested
especially in preclinical research
models and you can see on the right hand
side most of them they can be canonical
or non canonical meaning that if it's a
nuclear genomic pathways that means that
it directly affects the estrogen
receptor which is in the nucleus is a
transcription factor or it can be based
on independent of estrogen receptor that
means that there are alternative
pathways have been introduced mainly the
growth path retractor receptors EGFR her
two
idea are these are the mostly
established drug resistant mechanisms so
to further understand the whole
transcriptomic profile of endocrine
resistance we decided to use the
well-established drug endocrine
resistant breast cancer cell lines
mainly those cell lines are derived from
the endocrine resistant sense endocrine
sensitive Parenteau mcf7 cell - and
er-positive breast cancer cell line and
LCC su is the cell line that is treated
with the drug tamoxifen and with time
acquired a resistance to this drug and
LC c LC c 9 is the full western
resistance cell line which is treated
with the full restaurant and control
resistance with a bit in certain time
and it's also found out the tamoxifen
cross resistant - and besides this - or
models we also have plenty of data that
a gene called es rp1 mainly apt the
specific regulatory protein one is also
important in endocrine resistant
resistant cells so therefore we decided
to staple knockdown this and understand
that transcript elite profiling so here
is the the data that we have looked at
the using a qrt-pcr si es r p1
expression is elevated in endocrine
resistant cells so you see that the
light blue is the sensitive mcf7 cell
line if you compare the resistance cell
lines with that and you see that huge
dramatic overexpression of LC c to sign
language is tamoxifen resistance dark
blue and LC c 9 and for restaurant
resistant purple so they are
overexpressed compared to the
the sensitive mcf7 cell line so let me
give it a just very brief introduction
to ESR p-value which is epithelial
splicing regulatory protein it's as you
can see from the name its epithelial
cell type-specific splicing factor it
has been shown that it controls a
splicing of genes important in
epithelial mesenchymal transition which
is called EMT and this is important for
invasiveness of cancer cells including
breast cancer so it regulates
alternative splicing events and mostly
alternative cassette exons and however
it's not that much biological relevance
known in breast cancer and they are
potential clinical outcome so therefore
we decided to analyze this gene here
what we have done
first we stable in knockdown and with
this gene in these two endocrine and
resistance cell lines the upper panel
shows the qpcr qrt-pcr verification as
you see and the black is the resistant
format with the empty vector and then
you see the two clones light blue and
medium blue so the to c3 we chose based
on the maximum inhibition of this gene
and for the full western resistance on
the right hand side again the resistant
compared to the two clones the lighter
colors 9si to the maximum inhibitions or
we chose those two clones to further
undergo or functional and transcriptomic
analysis here on the lower panel you see
we introduce them to the mammary fat pad
[Music]
models which is important for breast
cancer analysis and then with the you
see a huge dramatic difference in the
tumor growth on the left hand side for
the clone
through CT 2 C 3 versus the resistant
version and on the right hand side T 9 C
2 which is the full restaurant
yes RP knockdown versus the resistant so
this further led us to understand the
alternative splicing differences first
because ESR payment is a splicing factor
so we expect that it's gonna important
to regulate splicing of the genes and
therefore the alternative splicing
events to look at it here you can see as
its earlier as I earlier said that it
effects the Casa Texans mainly skipped
axons or inclusion of exons in this
table we also a significant device the
majority of the events were longing to
skip exon opposite exons being 348
different exons corresponding to 289
genes and you see the other events also
existing although not dramatic as the
others but still existing so here you
see a genomic view of this analysis this
is the gene we looked at it as cd44 and
I will show this gene because it's a
well-established gene in terms of an
alternative splicing importance of
alternative splicing variants and
biological developments here you see on
the left hand side the end sound of
transcript numbers which you can you can
see which transcript which isoform is
having these multiple x own inclusion
versus the ones that they don't have it
so here in the very top the PS are exons
or probe specific regions you see the
red boxes all of them are excluded in
certain isoforms and not exclusion in
others but in the resistant form it is
included and in the es r p1 knockdown we
don't see it so there is a difference
between resistance and and and in non
resistance one so he
in this slide actually I would like to
show what that is this means in terms of
the biological importance exhausting or
including alters the function of the
cd44 and this also makes it compared to
the resistance so if you look at the
upper side the exons from 5a or 14
depends on what type of dish yourself
exon number may change however here if
it's included you have it's called cd44
variants form if it's excluded you call
it standard form and if you look at the
right hand side you see the structural
view and what it means in terms of
protein domains so here the site couple
is on the cd44 standard you see the
cytoplasmic domain transform a
transmembrane domain and internal domain
on the other side with the variant form
you see that there is an extra they
could stand here in the internal domain
so this extra form which is coming from
the inclusion of the exons actually
changes it is function so it makes or
confers resistance and make it more
invasive or importantly needed for
metastasis so as a conclusion from this
study we used redid the transcript
during analysis and identified
significantly altered alternative
splicing device in knockdown of ESR p1g
and as i give in the cd40 for example
alternative splicing alters the function
in the indus cells and it either makes
it resistant to the therapies or it
changes the sensitivity verses
resistance of the cells and so the next
step we would like to test the different
therapeutic agents to switch to
alternative and splicing events or in
the case of cd4 T or canvas abilities
very inform to the s phone and for the
other ones that's or next go to so as an
overall take-home messages but I would
like to say is of course the goal of the
study is important you can have a
discovery versus targeted approach you
may focus on high expresses or you want
to look at the low abundance transcripts
or you would like to do alternative
splicing whatever you choose I think the
importance is nowadays of course you
would like to look at the whole
transcript doing analysis because those
know codings or alternative splicing is
really part of the story to understand
the gene expression or you have to
understand the whole story
so that you can see what I'm gonna do in
the next step and the next gen a micro
arrays in this example clearing D
actually enabled us to understand the
mechanisms of drug resistance and this
will further enable us to use in the
future
targeted therapeutics which drugs we can
meeting should choose and I gave you two
examples from each of the preclinical
research studies for this for the
utility of this technology and as a
take-home message for the technical
aspect I would say I I would say the
advantages of clear MD for RNA seek is
first of all it's a probe based
technology because it's a the coverage
is extensive with multiple probes per
target and then it includes a huge
number of coding and non-coding it is
one si to go compared to the depth
coverage of the RNA sequencing and the
bio informatics is relatively simple
especially a molecule bar just like me
I would like to go
can fort with my red lab and then
analysis at the same time whatever data
i have i can immediately go and analyze
based on the new data very user-friendly
for the biologist and you can it covers
all the transcriptome analysis high low
abundance non-coding or antenna
alternative splicing it doesn't matter
it's a multi-purpose technique and
another as I mentioned previously I like
to see that it is you can go directly
from the software to the other browsers
UCSC or ensemble or others so that you
can understand what this region really
what this exon change on location really
means in terms of biology of the disease
and of course it's easier for adaptation
to preclinical studies like I showed you
and it will be a potential clinical news
in the future and the last but not least
it's very cost effective with this I
would like to thank to my collaborators
and lab numbers and of course to thermo
Fisher Scientific and our funding
sources thank you thank you so much dr.
Goodman Palmer for that informative
presentation and your important research
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask audience numbers
please do so now just click on that
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window type that
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button so
let's take a look at our audience member
questions that we have already coming in
the first question dr. Guzman poehler is
what are the similarities and
differences between coding and
non-coding RNAs to study in cancer
research
great question of course there are
similarities and dissimilarities so in
terms of similarities they are mostly
transcribed transcribe via our RNA
polymerase 2 they have poly elimination
and they can undergo alternative
splicing because they have exons on the
other hand there are challenges with the
non-coding rnas especially because they
mostly exert a regulatory role rather
than enzymatic functions so that makes
it no enzymatic essays available as
readouts or because you don't have a
protein expression you can't go by the
antibodies and look at the expression
and there are hard to find
readout essays another challenge is they
are expecting low levels so for knocking
and knockdown usually most of the
promoters are very much designed for a
messenger is that where high expression
is mostly desirable and therefore to
exactly mimic the same conditions for
the long long mouth noting Andy's
non-coding enemies are little bit more
difficult than the messenger knees
however one way to understand their role
will be to determine their sis and
trance mechanisms so you can use
computational essays and look at the the
exons that is affected and the motives
what kind of RNA motives you find there
these are actually lead to you further
understand what kind of pathway you can
focus and you can also look at the trans
mechanisms what other distance pathways
are affecting those ironies these are
the ways to study
thank you doctor you can Poehler
our next question from our audience is
what would you suggest as a next step
following identification of a splice
variant now it only depends where the
splicing occurs so it may affect the
cassette exone or five prime three prime
region or any other region but the most
important thing you have to connect this
region whether it's an important region
in terms of biologically so therefore
which I give the example for the mid-to
software that once you know the where
the location is and you can connect this
to other data sources like an example or
UCSC and you can understand the change
further you can connect to the protein
domains let's say 1.x own included
excluded if it effects a surgical and
protein domain that means that it alters
the function of the gene and as i give
in the cd4 t for example so including
the exomes affect the protein structure
and domain and therefore at the end it
also alters the function another thing
that mutations can appear a mutation can
cause splicing and also that affects
order the downstream biological effect
so it all depends where it happens
Thank You dr. Gookin polar and I want to
thank our wonderful audience today we
have time for one more question
our next question dr. Koopman polar is
what are the methods to understand the
role of alternative splicing that's a
great question but a difficult one of
course you can do the same thing that we
do for the messenger rna's you can knock
in or knock down the particular exon or
exons but this is of course more
challenging because you need to develop
mini genes
meaning that imaging is a minimal gene
fragment that includes an exon or the
control regions necessary for the gene
to express itself so you can develop the
same way as the wild-type or the major
form of this and you can also develop
more complex mini genes including
multiple exons that's one way other than
you can introduce the whole transcript
that is missing or excluding that exon
only or exons only so these are the
multiple ways that you can analyze
specific exon related essays
dr. guma and puller thank you so much
again for your presentation today and I
also want to thank elaborate and thermo
Fisher Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye
you